hey everybody this is Jeff from Naughty
Dog and I'm here to tell you about one
of our awesome new features included in
the Last of Us remastered for the
PlayStation 4 it's called photo mode
this new mode allows you to freeze the
action in the game adjust the camera and
add custom effects and frames before
sharing them with the share button on
the DualShock 4 let's take a more
detailed look at the new system first
activate photo mode on the pause screen
by toggling it on resume the game and
then just click the l3 button when you
got something you'd like to capture you
can enter photo mode any time other than
a cutscene though sometimes you'll be
restricted from moving the camera once
you're in photo mode you have access to
eight different menus to customize your
shot in the camera menu you can offset
the camera with the left stick orbit the
player with the right stick dolly the
camera enter out with l1 and r1 and roll
the axis of the camera with left and
right on the d-pad the field of view
menu allows you to zoom in or out with
the left stick this is great for
focusing on the little details on a
character or getting a big dynamic wide
shot you can also reset to the default
settings on any given menu by pressing R
3 in the depth of field menu you can
change what the camera has in focus you
can toggle the depth of field on and off
with left and right on the d-pad you can
also set the position of the focus with
the left stick
and adjust the width of the area and
focus with l1 and r1 in the color filter
menu you can select from a variety of
filters to set the mood of your shot
adjust the intensity of your chosen
effect with l1 and r1 the frame menu
allows you to select from a series of
borders to frame your shot just right in
the vignette menu you can darken the
corners of the image by toggling the
vignette on and off with left and right
on the d-pad you can also set the size
of the vignette with the left stick as
well as setting the intensity of the
vignette with l1 and r1 you can add some
grit to your shot by turning on film
grain just adjust the intensity of the
effect in the film grain menu with l1
and r1 if a particular area is too under
or overexposed you can lighten or darken
it in the brightness menu with l1 and r1
now that you got everything set you can
hide the UI with the X button to save
that perfect shot once you've framed up
your shot just press the share button to
save the image and upload for your
friends to check out you exit share mode
the same way you got in by clicking the
l3 button well that's about it for the
photo mode tutorial video thanks a lot
for checking it out we're really excited
about this new way you can share your
experience with the Last of Us
remastered for PlayStation 4 hope you
guys get some killer shots and who knows
some of those shots might become
important for some kind of a photo
contest or something anyways stay tuned
you
today's things